jean sébastien sauvé il est chargé de
cours à la faculté de droit de mercier
de mort et dans leurs jouets via skype
mais se sauver d'abord est-ce qu'on doit
des données quelle est l'étendue du
phénomène quand on parle de combien de
jeunes comme ça la question elle est
souvent posée ces derniers temps on
dirait que de plus en plus de personnes
qui qui sont rend ce jeu je pense pas
que ce soit une impression est en fait
je pense que c'est seulement une
impression devrais je plutôt dire qu' on
ne peut pas nécessairement rencontré une
explosion de nouvelles personnes trans
maintenant la question savoir il y en a
combien qui se trouvent au québec elle
est très très difficile à répondre parce
que souvent dans les dents les
recherches et bien on ne s'entendra pas
sûr qu'ils aient une personne trans et
si on s'entend pas sur la question
savoir qui est une personne trans est
gay c'est sûr que c'est là un impact sur
le nombre de personnes que l'on doit
considérer comme 30 une des données qui
est parfois utilisés dans les recherches
et nous vient de l'europe est un
chercheur était arrivé à là où ce
chiffre d'environ 1 enfant sur 5 cents
mais c'est une donnée qui est à prendre
avec beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
prudence parce que bien évidemment ça
fait encore référence à ceux qu'il a
considérés comme étant une personne
trans
bon qu'est ce que la loi dit là dans le
cas de david de david james d'azur
il n'a que 14 ans un enfant donc aux
chances de la loi est-ce qu'il peut
demander un changement légal de nom et
commencer à subir des traitements
médicaux pour changer de sexe
mais là c'est deux choses qu'il faut
qu'il faut distinguer en d'un côté on a
tout le volet administratif le volet qui
touche les papiers d'identité et d'un
autre côté on a le volet qui touche les
traitements médicaux et à un les
différentes interventions chirurgicales
qui pourraient être envisagées dans un
avenir plus ou moins rapproché
il faut savoir d'un côté c'est que pour
les personnes mineures qui sont acquis
sont trans le changement de mention de
sexe il est interdit avant l'âge de 18
ans donc la lettre qui apparaît sur les
documents d'identité le m ou le fc
là elle ne pourra pas être changé d'un
autre côté en ce qui a trait aux coûts
non là c'est possible d'obtenir un
changement non donc la personne qui a
été appelé par exemple avec un prénom
féminin pourrait si elle rencontre une
multitude de conditions qui sont exigés
par la loi
obtenir son changement de prénom pour un
prénom masculin dans la mesure où
évidemment les conditions qui sont
requises par la loi sont rencontrés
alors à ce moment-là ce que ça peut
créer simplement c'est sur les documents
d'identité
on veut y voir une certaine confusion
une certaine ambiguïté parce qu'on va
pouvoir voir un prénom féminin avec une
mention de sexe par exemple qui est
masculine est là bas ça pose de
multiples tracas au quotidien bon ça
c'est en ce qui a trait aux documents
d'identité en ce qui a trait au
traitement et chirurgie aider les soins
qui sont parfois prodigués aux personnes
trans ce sont des soins qui sont pris
très au sérieux ces des soins qui sont
requis par leur état de santé
et ça ça n'a pas du tout ça va
absolument rien à voir pardon avec la
question du changement mention de seize
ans a évolué en parallèle en tant que
tel d'accord je reviens à david eugène
d'azur pluie l'achat il a réussi à
changer le nom là bien sûr légalement
pas le chèque parce qu'il n'a pas 18 ans
comme vous dites mais pour changer de
nom c'est quand même pour rien a changé
de nom est ce que les parents doivent
signer est-ce que et vous dites une
série de conditions
par exemple quels sont ces conditions et
bien une des conditions par exemple la
personne doit avoir la citoyenneté
canadienne donc si la personne n'a pas
la citoyenneté canadienne en partant
elle ne pourra pas obtenir le changement
non évidemment comme la personne est
mineure les parents vont devoir
également se prononcer sur le sujet et
là il ya une multitude évidemment de
formulaires et qui doivent être remplies
également et il ya une autre condition
qu'ils sont beaucoup plus qu'ils sont de
l'ordre de l'administratif par exemple
payer 1 lire litres et qui sont exigés
par la loi très bien et dernière
question c'est important parce qu'on le
voit dans le cas de l'école en question
auraient ils ont essayé d'accommoder est
ce que l'école doit accorder un enfant
étranger
qui demande d'aller à une toilette soit
neutre soit de son nouveau c'est
certainement en ce qui a trait à la
question des toilettes on en parle
beaucoup en ce moment avec ce qui se
passe en général parce que c'est
important de le mentionner de façon très
précise les enfants trans ont le droit
d'accéder à la toilette qui répond le
mieux à leur identité de genre est ce
que ça veut dire c'est qu'on ne peut pas
forcer une personne à utiliser le nom
l'ordre des toilettes alors parfois
certaines solutions qui sont mises de
l'avant c'est de mettre à la disposition
des personnes trans une toilette de
genre neutre des gays mais il faut
savoir qu'on ne peut pas forcer cette
personne n'en a utilisé la toilette de
genre mal parce que vous savez si
l'enfant c'est le seul dans l'école a
utilisé la toilette de jean arnold bear
un certain moment donné les autres
élèves vont pouvoir se poser des
questions et on tape être une cible sur
cet enfant là ralentiront 30 secondes
dans le cas de david lui voulait aller
dans les toilettes pour garçons aulas
les colonies non on est mieux une et une
toilette note
l'école avait le droit de lui dire non à
sa victime et moi et vous savez le droit
est quelque chose de complexe et ça
appelle souvent à de multiples nuances
mais avec ce que vous me dites puis avec
ce que j'ai pu lire moi je doute que
l'école ait agi d'une façon respectueuse
de son droit légal et donc à mon avis on
est dans la présence d'un cas de
discrimination mais encore là chaque cas
est un cas d'espèce il faut faire
attention donc faudra aller plus loin
mais moi ce que je me poserais des
questions en tout cas ce n'est pas
terminée sur des bas puis vous faites
votre doctorat je n'ai pas préciser je
le précise
votre doctorat sur ces questions merci
beaucoup monsieur sauver merci beaucoup
et était un plaisir voire avoir alors